lâchez les mâts et laissez vous glisser
ne vous souhaitez pas jeter pas à les
unifier
ne vous jetez pas non vous jetez pas
vous allez faire un des plus grands
sauts au monde mon chéri vous êtes
aéromobile ils m'ont dit que j'avais un
masque parce que les dernières personnes
qui avaient tenté ça avait vu ce qu'il
fallait faire avait renoncé en cours en
bas c'est ça non mais c'est vrai qu'on
joue c'est vrai mais si vous êtes le
plus courageux de la banque vous le
savez mon gillou gillou chérie je vous
entends ça va toujours mieux je sais
gilles avant avant bien sûr de prendre
place sur le toboggan est ce que gilles
mon cher est ce que vous voulez me dire
un dernier mot ce que voulait dire un
dernier mot aux personnes qui vous sont
chères m
vous savez oui ma maman comme ça même de
leur monde me paraît supportable
[Applaudissements]
c'est maxime ce qui se passe ici c'est
belgique gilles on va vous mettre en
place à se mettre en place gilles les
cherry sur le toit des 8
il va faire un saut ne sais plus combien
de mètres l'un c'est vraiment je crois
que c'est combien de mètres le lot de
lotto beau ses étages 6 et 13 bateaux
pour moi parce que c est pas là vous
l'embrassez pour moi quand on va voir ce
pas tout bien sûr
jlm est aidé en place at assurant la
l'avons fait peur vous me faites peur
faites attention faites gaffe à lui
énorme attention là prenez pas de
risques les gars prenez pas de risques
les gares et les gars faites gaffe c'est
pas légal mais lola sepa sepa
non mais les gars faites gaffe vous
savez qui me fait peur mais moi j'ai
peur là arrêtez les gars vous êtes sûr
de vos gars là parce qu'ils m'ont l'air
un peu trop longtemps la dent et même
moi parce que j'ai peur quand même de le
dire
non sans charlie parce que je pense
qu'ils font là c'est risqué quand même
on sait jamais si pas d'élection sur
deux toiles à une font peur gilles
mettez vous aux places mais taylor en
place je veux pas voir ça m'a presque
ils sont vraiment sur le tour allez si
j'avais mettez le bios torpeur mais
mettez l'eau bien en place mais jamais
je lâche mon micro wii wheel avec mon
micro la chaleur
merci mettez le en place maintenant
parce mettez les jambes devant comme si
vous étiez sur un toboggan
comme si vous étiez sur un toboggan
peut-être en avant nous allons chez vous
comme une option at home ou non obtenu
via le toboggan vraiment mais non comme
simulation toboggan mettez-vous meinau
mettez-vous à plat ventre la vente après
l'autre à plat ventre
oui à plat ventre bah oui c'est comme ça
sinon il va lui et risque de se blesser
rigolez pas dire avoue quand même à dieu
un dieu j
attendez attendez il concerne la
sécurité jules ne vous jetez pas à
laissez vous glisser
d'accord d'accord parce que ça nous
plaît vous faire mal laissez-vous
jusqu'ici sans la glisse et lâcher les
mâts et laissez vous glisser ne vous
souhaitez pas jeter pas à les unifier
vous jetez pas non vous jetez pas
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c
j'aime ça va ça va mieux
voilà bravo module venez nous rejoindre
les cafetières de jean luc rigaut la
richesse combo dû revoir le show avec le
son avec le saura que son s'il vous
plaît c'est fou c'est fou
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et